oui figaro live merci d'être avec nous
il est 15 14h54 nous sommes en direct
pour suivre vous le voyez sur les images
derrière nous ces images où le voyez de
la première sortie dans l'espace d'une
équipe entièrement constitué de femmes
c'est une première historique que nous
vivons ensemble sur la page principale
du figaro sur facebook mais également
sur twitch nous prenons tous vos
commentaires et toutes vos questions
nous sommes avec cyril van der berg
merci beaucoup de toulouse avec nous
vous êtes rédacteur en chef
si on faisait médecine au figaro vous
êtes bien un fervent connaisseur de
voilà de l'espace de 2 tout ce qui
fonctionne là autour de la station
spatiale internationale que l'on peut
voir sur ses écrans et donc on va suivre
avec vous et avec vous dans le tchat sur
sur facebook et sur twitter également
n'hésitez pas à nous poser toutes vos
questions
cette première historique alors tout
d'abord en effet cyril ce n'est pas la
première fois que des femmes sont dans
l'espace qu'il ya heureusement toutefois
c'est la première fois qu'elle sorte
certes on semble entièrement constitué
en fait il ya eu à peu près 200 sorties
dans l'espace sont ressortis en
scaphandre depuis les débuts de la
station spatiale internationale donc
c'est quand même considérable il ya que
quinze femmes en fête qui sont sortis en
scaphandre et là on a une jolie première
c'est vraiment une jolie c'est un beau
symbole de des efforts canada fait pour
féminiser la profession d'astronautes
donc deux femmes en même temps et c'est
donc christine accord qui est d'une part
on on a un petit truc pour les
reconnaître et christina corps d'un côté
et l'autre côté il ya de jessica vers
ware et pour les reconnaître
parce qu'elles ont un scaphandre qu'on
ne va pas voir leur visage il faut
savoir que en fait le lever à la peau
moment et les relever à la sortie
extravéhiculaire donc cette sortie en
dehors de l'ailier cesse et scaphandre
une petite différence une inquiète les
bandes rouge sur les épaules et sur les
cuisses et ça c'est le scaphandre de
christine accord et l'autre scaphandre
complètement blanc c'est donc cette
logistique awer jessica werle à l'autre
l'autre particularité c'est que c'est sa
première sortie en scaphandre c'était
est arrivée dans la station en septembre
et c'est un beau baptême du feu pour
elle parce que elle participe à une
première série voit la sortie historique
et alors c'est quelque part c'est à la
fois historique et aussi assez banal
donc parce que
parce que cette sortie c'est en fait
c'est du de la réparation
ils sortent de là quand on sort de la
station quand on se met en danger dans
un scaphandre ce qu'on a comme dans le
vide spatial
et ils n'ont plus à l'abri de des
modules qui sont bien des dents la
station est bien ici une très bonne
raison pour le faire et que c'est
quelque chose qu'on peut pas faire de
l'intérieur et là en fait il ya une
phase en fait de mise à jour des
batteries la station la batterie c'est
la station iss vous connaissez sûrement
c'est en ait un donc c'est un
laboratoire orbital à 400 kilomètres
d'altitude au dessus de la surface de la
terre et c'est grand comme deux terrains
de foot à peu près ça pèse 400 tonnes et
il ya là on est on est on vient de
sortir la phase nuit et donc les
panneaux solaires sont de nouveau au
soleil et mais en revanche quand là
quand la station passe derrière entre
entre la terre et le soleil et ben il
n'y a plus il faut là il faut des
batteries pour stocker l'électricité
on va revenir sur les détails de cette
opération de réparation donc c'est pour
ses batteries qui sont changés vous le
voyez en direct sur cr7 sur ses écrans
mats thibault s'est pas les batteries
les batteries en fait les batteries ont
déjà été changés fonctionne bien c'est
un boîtier de commande électroniques qui
commandent la charge et la décharge des
bananes quoi d'accord alors on va on va
revenir dessus plus en détail pour
comprendre un peu mieux ce qui se passe
actuellement sur ces images j'en profite
pour bien venir vous saluer dans dans le
chatt bonjour à vous sylvie bonjour josé
bonjour à vous
mais remettent esteban marie nattes ou
encore philippe vous êtes nombreux à
commenter et à nous nous exprimer bien
voilà votre votre votre voix votre
soutien en tout cas pour pour cette
nouvelle sortie je vais lire quelques
uns de vos commentaires nathalie qui
nous dit formidable bravo les filles
quel courage marie qui nous dit goggles
bras vous de la part également de celui
qui nous dit que c'est historique
bonjour en tout cas à vous et merci
beaucoup de nos cieux n'hésitez pas à
commenter et surtout à nous poser toutes
vos questions sur et bien voilà ce qui
fait de cette journée une journée
historique
cyril pour pour la conquête de l'espace
tout simplement oui oui c'est un jour
important c'est c'est pas un hasard en
fait enfin ça à la fois pas un hasard
quelque chose qui n'est pas programmé en
tant que tel par la nasa
c'est dire que ce n'est pas une c'est
pas un coup juste un coup de pub de la
nasa qui veut dire voilà on féminise on
met plus astronautes femmes
en fait voilà c'était dans le nom de
calendrier des rotations et des sorties
ça aurait pu se passer déjà il ya six
mois en fait oui là me garder il ya eu
un petit couac à l'époque c'était
c'était la même christine accord donc et
et une autre astronaute américaine ann
mcclain qui devait sortir ensemble pour
faire une autre sortie et ian mcshane
elle s'est aperçu un peu un peu
tardivement qu'elle est en fait qui a
été plus à l'aise dans le scaphandre de
taille moyenne que dans celui de grande
taille et donc il n'y avait pas cette
petite qu'à fondre dans la station pour
le moment où il y était et est ce que
finalement dans l'est dans les
préparatifs et il ne considérait pas que
il pourrait y avoir deux femmes dans
l'espace ça a été un peu interprété
comme ça alors oui on s'était pas
exactement ça en fait c'était s'était
pas deux femmes dans l'espace ou pas de
deux petits deux hommes petits parce que
d'accord pour être honnête relais sont
pas ils sont pas des scaphandres ils
sont aussi bien pour les hommes que pour
les femmes
non le problème c'est que dans la
station n'y a pas beaucoup de place donc
il faut il ya que quelques scaphandre
qui sont stockés et là depuis je crois
depuis cet été ils ont remonté un
scaphandre de taille moyenne donc il y
aura plus de problèmes à l'avenir pour
faire des sorties de deux femmes en même
temps même si elles sont petites
vous êtes nombreux toujours a commenté
dans le chat que vous nous suiviez sur
la page principale du figaro sur
facebook ou encore sur twitch bonjour à
vous et merci de me suivre
michael sophie ou encore jo je vais
revenir tout de suite sur sur vos
commentaires vous êtes vous êtes
nombreux à voile à vous exprimer on a
par exemple ce commentaire de djoko
revinois qui nous dit il était temps
j'ai 85 ans depuis trois jours et bien
oui en effet vous avez vous pouvez
observer aujourd'hui avec nous cette
première historique une sortie donc 100%
féminine dans l'espace marie vous nous
dites que même si ce ne sont que des
réparations à effectuer sur la station
cela reste fantastique merci pour ces
images merci à vous d'être avec nous
n'hésitez pas à commenter à nous dire ce
que ce que vous pensez de cette journée
et surtout n'hésitez pas également à
nous poser toutes vos questions vous
allez voir on va pouvoir revenir un peu
plus en détail sur cette sortie et sur
ses particularités sophie vous le dit
que voilà vous trouvez cela incroyable
vous regardez de l'australie et bien
bonjour sophy merci beaucoup d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui
et voilà donc en tout cas merci d'être
avec nous je le répète mais voilà
bonjour nadia par exemple qui venait
juste de nous rejoindre
voilà si vous avez des questions on les
prend tout je vous le rappelle que vous
soyez avec nous sur twitter et sur la
page principale du figaro ou sur
facebook
alors on disait une première historique
est ce qu'il ya des femmes qui dans
l'histoire de la conquête de l'espace
ont marqué alors te voir également
ben voilà c'est arrivé de l'homme et de
la femme donc oui oui et les et la
première la première phase le moment en
partant sur la première femme dans
l'espace et valentina terechkova à
l'époque c'était l'union soviétique qui
a accumulé les premières et donc mais sa
première mission est pas enfin c'était
c'était vraiment pour le coup là un coup
de pub et savez savez était pas dans
votre place est mal passé pour cette
pauvre valentina terechkova qui après
est vraiment devenue une héroïne de
l'union soviétique qui a eu des postes
de grandes responsabilités au au plus
haut du parti communiste soviétique
mais oui enfin il ya enfin les femmes
volent son astronautes depuis quand même
pas mal d'années
christina coque où on entre on voit
l'image du casque la lente tout de suite
là c'est un bon exemple en fait elle est
elle en est à son c'est sa quatrième
sortie dans l'espace dont elle et elle
est déjà c'est parce que c'est un aussi
ce qui est quand même très très
particulier qui est physiquement très
éprouvant on voit là l'image là elle
tient celles qui rendent une perceuse
visseuse et vous voyez la taille de
l'engin et cet engin en plus on l'a vu
tout à l'heure elle cherchait des outils
dans un an sans le bac à outils et tout
flotte ni rien qui rien qui ait faim
tout flotte aérienne tient en place et
donc utiliser quelques choses aussi
basiques une visseuse déjà on voit main
droite elle se tient solidement au
châssis de la station pour pas tourner
en même temps que la perceuse un coup de
perceuse ça crée une énergie finalement
qui va on tourne autour de la perceuse
et donc il faut se tenir il faut enfin
voilà on voit on voit là la visseuse qui
est qui dévisse c'est quelque chose sur
terre c'est très simple dans l'espace
avec des gants qui sont très épais et
qui demande près 20 de force pour les
manipuler tous les gestes et tout
devient compliqué en fait donc christina
cox
elle est à sa quatrième sortie dans
l'espace on peut dire déjà qu'ils
aillent vraiment expérimenté et c'est
pour ça qu'elle commande cette sortie et
qui en tant que numéro un jusqu'à
prendre en moyenne d'ailleurs un
astronaute qui est dans la station
spatiale internationale va faire combien
de sortie au total dans l'espace
alors en fait la plus la plupart ne font
pas d'accord c'est vrai ça reste quelque
chose d'exceptionnel notre notre favori
français thomas pesquet on a fait 2 et
c'était vraiment enfin c'était et tous
les tous les astronautes français n'ont
pas fait de sortie dans l'espace dans ce
cas font donc d'accord loin de là c'est
pas c'est pas de la routine on est
vraiment dans quelque chose de tout
alors quelqu'un avait dit oui c'est
peut-être juste d'une réparation mais
c'est quand même fantastique oui c'est
un sursis que ça reste quelque chose de
dangereux on est dans un espace qui est
il ya le vide spatial et des écarts de
température incroyable entre le jour et
la nuit
il ya le risque permanent de micro
météorites qui peut transpercer le
scaphandre on voit sur les mains le
soleil sur les gants de christina cox
on voit qu'il ya des petits miroirs je
passe souvent les voitures on les voit
c'est bien la quête de l'image est pas
terrible hein surtout qu'il a la
transmission allait racheter h et
devraient revoir leur fibre on voit
d'abord et en fait des des miroirs sur
ses poignets et si miroir il sert il lui
servent à vérifier sur son propre cas
funky et pas d'impact qui apparaît trop
qui aimeraient d'accros il faut il faut
éviter bien on imagine y aller il ya des
parties métalliques et les partis qui
peut être un peu coupante
il faut pas que le scaf on s'aligne il
faut pas se mettre en danger bien sûr
donc toutes les je dirais voilà tous les
toutes les 10 minutes de la sortie il
faut faire ces vérifications qui sont la
routine et qui sont commandés est
demandée par le cap comme kalou là pour
le couple c'est la capcom c'est un
ancien mot qui vient de déprogrammer de
capsules américain c'est capsule
communicateur donc c'est un astronaute
ou une astronaute qui est à houston et
qui suit en direct ce qui se passe qui a
exactement le même programme et le
déroulé des actions affaire qui sait ce
que c'est qui a l'expérience d'une
sortie dans l'espace et qui donne à la
fois le timing et les conseils et les
instructions
dudu du centre de commande à houston
alors merci à vous de nous suivre
aujourd'hui pour cette journée
importante dans l'histoire spatiale
bonjour à vous
jean bachir marie-louise henry corinne
ou encore marvin vous êtes nombreux à
commenter sur facebook lent l'occurrence
n'hésitez pas si vous le suivez sur
twitter et sur la page principale de
figure on prend également tous vos
commentaires et toutes vos questions
je rebondis d'ailleurs sur sur un
commentaire le vôtre marvin sainte-luce
vous nous rappeler certains chiffres
intéressants qui montre bien
l'importance de cette journée
cinq cent soixante quatre astronautes au
total 1 dans l'histoire seulement 65
femmes soit 11%
il y a eu 221 une sortie dans l'espace
depuis les débuts de la station examiné
plus que ça les russes on en fait aussi
adacore américaine et donc dans l'espace
dans quelques unes seulement ont été
effectuées par des femmes et alimente
toujours été accompagné par un homme
alors vous êtes nombreux à réagir dans
le tchat
déjà pour les féliciter comme vous par
exemple corinne qui dit bravo les filles
bonjour avoue marie louise merci de nous
rejoindre
bonjour à vous bachir également voilà
alors après jean nous dit trop
s'extasier sur le fait que ce soient des
femmes
n'est-il pas un signe qu'on les pneus
les pensées pas capable avant alors en
tout cas en ce qui concerne la station
spatiale internationale où on a quand
même compter des femmes au sein des
équipages est forcément là maintenant
aujourd'hui ça devient de plus en plus
démocratisé cette présence des femmes
d'ailleurs au sein de la nasa par
exemple est-ce que est-ce qu'il ya
beaucoup de femmes est-ce qu'on voit une
des évolutions lathion oui oui elle est
lé recrutement d'astronautes pendant son
sont paritaires donc les prochaines
générations sont vraiment paritaire sont
autant de femmes d'hommes que de femmes
et dans le nouveau plan d'exploration et
le projet de la nasa de retourner sur la
lune
le programme s'appelle athéna et c'est
pas un hasard si c'est un nom d'une
déesse parce que l'intention la nasa
c'est que ce soit une femme qui
remettent le pied sur le pied sur la
lune
alors c'est le projet que les projets
officiels cd 1024 mais ça sera peut être
un peu plus tard alors une seconde
question d'ailleurs est ce que en ce qui
concerne la conquête de mars
on a déjà sur les questions de parité
par exemple des statistiques non parce
que il ya pour le moment il n'y a pas d'
il n'y a pas de vrais plans pour aller
sur mars
c'est encore trop compliqué trop loin la
lune ces trois jours de voyage mars
c'est entre 3 et 6 mois à l'ail simple
il faut rester six mois là sur place et
six mois de retour donc cesser les
voyages beaucoup plus long en gros
marson nippon n'est pas qu'un jeu de le
faire donc il n'y a pas mois que
l'espagne a pas d'équipage prévu en fait
là s'il n'y a pas une sortie sans
pension féminine aujourd'hui jusqu'à
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'était pas une
question de capacité elles sont
évidemment tout tout tout aussi capables
que les hommes de faire des sorties en
scaphandre c'est juste qu'avec comme il
y avait moins d'astronautes femme qui
avait quand même beaucoup on ne
probabilité que deux femmes se retrouver
ensemble au même moment pour faire une
sortie dans l'espace bonjour à vous
esteban vous nous suivez sur facebook et
nous dit bien que l'espace fera rêver
les humains toujours et en tout temps
c'est vrai que c'est un objectif et du
coup a bien évidemment tout ce qui se
passe là haut est un peu historique à
chaque première fois c'est en tout cas
une journée historique pourrait bien la
conquête spatiale avec donc on vous le
rappelle la présence en sortie pour des
réparations ici alors vous l'expliquer
c'est un peu complexe
ce n'est pas pour changer les batteries
comme on a pu voir dans de nombreux
articles c'est pour changer une moitié
de contrôle électronique qui contrôle la
charge et à décharge des batteries on a
remplacé les anciennes batteries par des
batteries lithium ion lithium ion fait
on connaît tous c'est ce qu'on a tous
dans smartphones c'est ce qui ce qui
permet d'avoir plus de capacités va avec
moins de place et moins de poids et bien
sûr la station ils ont ils ont gagné
aussi avec ses progrès technologique et
la contrainte c'est qu'il faut gérer ses
batteries de manière un peu différente
des générations précédentes
il ya notamment un impératif que les
batteries lithium-ion je sais pas si
vous le savez pour smartphones mais il
faut jamais les décharger complètement
si votre téléphone ça c'est un de
lui-même quand la batterie est
et à placer que c'est pour éviter de la
décharger complètement il a abîmé la
batterie d'accord c'est une protection
et c'est ce genre de protection
électronique dont on a besoin quand on
charles ont géré la charge
l'autre contrainte c'est la température
les batteries lithium même pas la
chaleur il faut donc que le taux de
charge soient pas trop rapide pour
éviter que ça se fasse ça chauffe donc
voilà c'est un boîtier électronique qui
est pas si compliqué que ça mais il est
là il est en panne donc il pouvait pas
utiliser les nouveaux lots de batterie
ce qui est quand même gênant quand on
sait que monde et plusieurs sorties dans
l'espace pour les as pour être installée
et voilà alors comment ça fonctionne
en termes d'entraînement là on dirait
quand on voit les images pour là on a
une autre facette de l'association face
et internationales mais tout à l'heure
on pouvait voir une vue à la première
personne de l'une des des deux
astronautes
est ce que j'imagine que ça demande même
pour des simples opérations ça demande
énormément d'entraînement
oui en fait alors là la particularité
c'est que la mission qu'elles sont en
train de faire elle n'a pas été
forcément été répétée en l'entraînant à
houston parce que c'est quelque chose
d'imprévu c'est d'une panne qu'il faut
qu'il faut réparer en revanche toutes
les miens énorme piscine au centre
spatial à houston au texas qui est en
fait ce qu'ils appellent un laboratoire
flottaison nul en fait quand on est les
cantons de fond en ayant plongé même en
scaphandre et bien on a les mêmes en a à
peu près les mêmes sensations qu'en
apesanteur c'est à dire qu'on est au
ballon flotte avec une légère différence
est que dans l'espace
il n'y a pas de frottement donc quand
vous commencez une rotation ou en
mouvement
si vous faites rien pour l'arrêter il se
continue alors que dans une piscine
l'aube a freiné assez vite émouvant mais
tout tout et répété il ya en fait il ya
des modules de la station qui sont à
taille réelle dans cette piscine géante
d'accord et on s'entraîne à la fois à
sortir de la station c'est le geste
peut-être le plus difficile à faire
c'est c'est ça c'est ouvrir les
écoutilles et se retrouver avec la terre
en dessous avec le no id autour de soi
c'est ça peut filer la pétoche en termes
de risque l'histoire est ce qu'on a déjà
eu des accidents des problèmes pour
certains alors la première sortie dans
l'espace parce qu'enfin elle a failli
très mal se terminer
c'était aller alors c'est un peu un peu
triste et alexei leonov un soviétique et
on april et il est mort cette semaine en
fait illégal et donc c'était un grand à
des grands héros soviétique de la
conquête spatiale et nuit il était sorti
c'était page et plus la date en tête
mais celle du début des années 60 il se
rend scaphandrier tout seul dans ces
instants sa capsule vostok est et tout
se passe bien il est aujourd'hui il est
quand même relié
la torche il fait sa sortie il prend une
photo tout va bien il faut rentrer dans
la quatrième île quand il veut rentrer
la capsule il se rend compte qu'en fait
l'oxygène qui pressurise son scaphandre
l'empêchent de rentrée d'accord donc ils
n'arrivent pas à rentrer dans sa capsule
il ya évidemment personne pour l'aider
parce qu'il est tout seul tout seul à
bord et bah là ils font un sang froid
incroyable c'est ce qu'il a fait c'est
qu'il a commencé à dégonfler son
scaphandre le dépressurisé un petit peu
pour pouvoir entrer et se mettre à
l'abri dans sa capsule donc on y note
c'était c'était à l'époque le niveau
d'apprentissage qui avait c'est que l'on
savait pas comment ça se comporter et
toutes les premières étaient extrêmement
dangereuse maintenant normalement là on
a érodé
on est plus rodé le scaphandre sont
quand même mieux conçus et même s'ils
sont anciens ils sont ces scaphandre qui
ont été conçus pour les pros début des
programmes navettes spatiales donc ces
années 80 ce qui explique aussi
peut-être le fait qu'on ait plus de
combinaisons pour les grandes tailles à
l'époque il y avait moins de femmes
voilà mai
la conquête spatiale progresse la nasa
pense que cette semaine lé nouveau
scaphandre qui vont servir pour
l'exploration de la lune
oui en effet présenté par une femme
d'ailleurs oui si c'est symbolique je
passais pas symbolique c'est vraiment
une ambition c'éatit voilà montré que
que les femmes sont aussi capables que
les hommes à faire ce genre de travail
et mais voilà est en fait il ya eu alors
non là où c'est intéressant on voit bien
on voit bien là les et la manière dont
on se déplace sur la station c'est
toujours toujours se tenir
en fait il ya il ya un mousqueton donc
eu un câble avec un mousqueton qui est
accroché à la taille du scaphandre qui
suit une ligne de vie qui reliait la
station et il faut tout le temps tenir
là je crois que c'est ji sung jessica
ware qui se déplace on voit les panneaux
solaires sur le fond la suspicion est un
peu saccadée parce qu'elle passe par des
satellites relais d'accord qui sont
opérés par la nasa autour de la terre on
est quand même à 400 km d'altitude et la
station et voyages vite et le voyage
très très vite
pendant trente mille kilomètres heure
autour de la terre et c'est pour ça
qu'on ferait un tour un tour de la terre
toutes les 80 minutes toutes les heures
trente ans quand j'en passe assez
rapidement d'une phase ni à une phase
jours et c'est évidemment pour ça qu'on
a besoin de batterie pour stocker
l'électricité
alors en ce qu'il en est vous l'entendez
d'ailleurs on peut entendre les
différents concernés échanger entre eux
qu'est ce qui se dit d'ailleurs dans ce
genre d'opération là qu'est ce qu'on
peut entendre par exemple alors alors en
fait c'est très
et peu de discussions c'est pas des
discussions au coin du feu c'est
vraiment très technique c'est il ya un
programme qui a établi minute par minute
avec les un nombre d'opérations tous les
objets tous les ulti on voit les outils
cas qui flottent en dehors de sa classe
et ça illustre assez bien là qu'est la
difficulté de travailler dans ces
conditions là c'est quelque chose aussi
simple que de prendre un outil dans une
boîte à outils eh ben c'est déjà quelque
chose de pas sûr que ça et tous les
outils sont évidemment relié au sac pour
user qui s'échappe et qu'ils aillent se
balader et se transformer en débris
spatiaux on imagine les débris qui
voyagent à 30000 km heure ci vient
toucher quoi que ce soit c'est la
catastrophe
donc ne rien lâcher ne rien perdre ça
fait partie des contraintes des
contraintes
très très particulière pour ce genre
d'exercice s'est jamais la routine alors
là j'avoue que je suis un peu perdue je
sais pas sur quelle partie de la station
se déplacent jessica were j'essaie de
voir on voit les panneaux solaires je
pense qu'on est sur le sur le bras
central qui relie les panneaux solaires
au réseau la station on voit que c'est
quand même quelque chose d'assez
technique 1 on a pour rassembler ces
stations spatiales il a fallu plus d'une
centaine de missions donc presque autant
de vols en navette des vols de fusées
russes qui ont amené des modules aussi
faim donc c est un assemblage qui a été
très long et qui dès le départ en fait a
nécessité de faire des cd sorti en
scaphandre et la nasa est un peu en
train de changer de la vie sur ces
procédures là on est plutôt en train de
partir sur des manants se diffuser le
monde
le puissant capable d'emporter dur en
une seule fois
qu'est ce que les charges plus lourdes
et donc qui enlève le besoin de faire
des assemblages compliqué avec des
petits éléments en orbite au moins deux
sorties en scaphandre moins de risques
peut-être et une me voilà une
construction qui devrait être plus
rapide dans la l'image est assez
saccadée on est ronde et passer sur la
caméra de casques de christine accord
elle travaille indépendamment l'une de
l'autre
elle doit avoir des tâches qui sont
répartis par houston tout ça c'est
vraiment très programmée très très bien
répartis et je n'agis pas écouté j'ai
pas écouter à ses sens assez près pour
savoir exactement à quelle partie de la
sortie elle se trouve alors merci à vous
qui nous suivait sur la page principale
du figaro sur facebook ou sur twitter
on avait une question d'alban merci de
nous suivre qui delà des questions de
parité nous en demander où en étais sur
la place de l'europe dans la conquête
spatiale alors je rappelle d'ailleurs
qu'en suivant l'envoi deux astronautes à
l'extérieur de la station spatiale
internationale qu'au total ils sont six
dans la station donc deux américaines on
l'a dit un américain andrew morgan de
son nom deux russes et un italien luca
parmitano alors et luca parmitano c'est
un astronaute de l'agencé spatiale
européenne et c'est lui en ce moment qui
est commandant de bord de la station
spatiale internationale
d'accord alors lol la position de
l'europe c'est une très bonne question
en fait c'est depuis pas mal d'années
l'europe a fait le choix d'être
partenaire de ces programmes habité mais
n'a pas les moyens de lancer elle-même
ses propres astronautes dont on dépend
en fait pour le moment c'est les russes
ont les astronautes européens comme
thomas pesquet il décolle à bord d'une
capsule soyouz
là dans le futur à les américains ils
développent des nouvelles capsules qui
vont prendre le relais et qui vont
permettre aux américains de repartir un
espace sans être dépendant des russes
l'europe a fait le choix de pas de
garder ses fusées ariane pour lancer les
satellites mais il n'y a pas eu de
programme
voilà deux en fait c'est très coûteux
développé une nouvelle capsule
développer un nouveau vaisseau spatial
seller des milliards d'euros l'europe
l'a fait pour faire un cargo quitte à
les ravitailler la station spatiale
internationale s'appelait la tv et rien
que c'était un cargo automatique dans
quelque chose de
vraiment personnes à bord mais avec des
contraintes qu'on appelle et contraint
du vol habité donc il fallait qu'ils
aient des règles sûreté qui soit
draconiennes pas ce que l'on veut on
vient s'amarrer une station dans lequel
il ya six astronautes
il faut pas qu'on vient de mettre en
danger et ce programme là il a été
extrêmement coûteux pour faire voler au
final 6,6 vaisseau cargo
plusieurs milliards d'euros pour eux
donc voilà un programme habiter l'europe
est pas prête à payer aujourd'hui
ou en tout cas n'a pas considéré que
c'était dans ses priorités
donc on est on est partenaires en
fournissant soit des modules l'europe a
fourni un module laboratoire dans la
station qui s'appelle columbus et en
fournissant des missions de
ravitaillement mais voilà leur papa les
moyens d'y aller tout seul on est en
statut de partenaire c'est un peu la
même chose pour les japonais de temps en
temps mais pas les moyens d en vrille
mais une dernière question avant qu on
sculpte sirigu berbère je rappelle vous
êtes rédacteur en chef science et santé
au figaro justement restons dans
l'actualité
quels sont les prochains rendez vous
pour les amateurs d'espacé alors là
c'est la question un peu des bruits gym
était pas préparé un pardon je sais pas
s'il ya des grosses des gros des groupes
moins d'actu qu'on attend si si si le un
des gros enjeux serbe
il a d'abord politique fort en d'accord
une conférence des ministres de l'espace
en europe qui va se réunir en novembre
et ça va d'ici notamment deux aces que
l'europe passe à des fusées
réutilisables comme ce que fait ce p 6
ou est ce qu'on continue avec une
nouvelle jeune nouvelle génération de
fusées entre guillemets jetables comme
la comme celle car n 6 qui est en cours
de conception
donc voilà un gros enjeu politique après
en février l'europe va lancer février
2020 alors en bas santé lancée cela
orbiteur c'est une sonde d'études du
soleil assez exceptionnel en
collaboration avec la nasa et en 2020 il
y aura on espère de lancement très
important vers mars dernier une mission
qui s'appelle américaine qui s'appelle
mars 20 20 qui va lancer un gros rover
donc un gros robot à 6 roulettes à six
roues s'est pas déroulé c'est vraiment
des roues c'est quelque chose
800 kg et c'est le premier c'est la
première étape pour aller chercher un
échantillons de roches sur marche de
mars par l'ong et le ramener sur terre
et l'europe aussi à une mission qui
s'appelle exomars 2020 qui doit partir
au elle aussi envoyer un robot roulant
sur mars mais là du côté européen il n'y
a plus d'inquiétude ce qui a des
problèmes de parachute
les tests n'ont pas été concluants il ya
eu au départ je suis déchiré il s'empara
chez qui ne trouve pas ce sera demain
tout le jeu pense que le style et les
problèmes parachute sont pas résolues
d'ici quelques mois leur offre in the
repoussait de deux ans sa mission vers
mars
d'accord un grand merci de nous avoir
apporté vos lumières sur ces images
qu'on va vous laisser continuer de
suivre un petit peu avant de vous de
vous quitter
un grand merci à vous sur la page
principale du figaro sur facebook ou sur
twitter merci de nous avoir suivis comme
vous sylvie jo vincent je crois il y
avait bachir ou encore cédric vous étiez
nombreux à être avec nous et à nous
poser toutes vos questions
on vous donne et bien rendez vous très
vite pour là pour de nouveaux contenus
sur figaro livestream
à commencer par bien dans moins d'une
heure puisque nous allons bien débriefé
de la sphère balkany et on vous rappelle
qu'une audience était en cours il y à il
ya quelques heures aujourd'hui et que et
bien le couple balkany vient d'être
vient d'être condamné à de la prison
ferme donc on va essayer de débriefer
tout cela avec pierre pis les animateurs
figaro live et stéphane durand souffland
qui était au tribunal tout à l'heure
pour suivre cette audience
on vous laisse avec ces dernières images
et on vous dis à très vite sur filet
chamakh
abidal night work but your back mdm side
by side émouvant
m
pourquoi
et
10h07
après que trois pattes
[Musique]
baroin
ginette on est montré